well here at the Natural History Museum
in New York City to see the unveiling of
spaceship two now this is the spacecraft
that the Virgin Group hopes will
inaugurate commercial space travel and
it's not as crazy as it sounds do they
they've hired the best in the business
Scaled Composites which built spaceship
one that went to space in 2004 the first
private spaceship to actually reach
space without any government help of any
kind the other thing that everyone here
is waiting to hear answers to is what
happened last summer there was an
accident at the Scaled Composites test
and three people were killed three more
foot in the hospital it was terrible
thing but as for Scaled Composites but
but also for this this emerging industry
of commercial space travel there's
something about entrepreneurs that beats
in their heart and soul every day many
of us have the regular heartbeat they
have something that's a little different
and it's a beat that says why not why
not is this gonna be a safe system safe
enough for you to fly I wouldn't do it
if I didn't think you were same same to
know
it'd be great we have confidence that
that risk is minimized
that makes me comfortable to fly way it
works is this ship is going to take off
go to a high altitude with the spaceship
slowing underneath and once they get to
fifty thousand feet or so the station's
going to drop off
go into freefall and then light their
rocket engine and then this thing is
going to power up the space going past
Mach three all by itself while they the
White Knight two will peel off and then
you'll get about four minutes of
weightless flying of the earth have an
experience that very few people have had
at this point I can't spoil for you
why is important for a private company
to do this in addition to the government
or instead of only the elite would be
flying coast to coast the rest of us
would be pooping it or or driving space
needs that boost that the creativity
that comes with handing it over to
entrepreneurs for business and the fact
that this system will have the
capability to launch small payloads and
satellites at low cost is hugely
important
I keep telling Richard to be adventurous
more important than safety
really set on safety what caused that
explosion on the test stand last summer
which three employees were killed three
more put in the hospital to find the
answer they need to understand more
properly how nitrous oxide behaves in
certain conditions is something that
hasn't been done a lot in industry
nitrous oxide is used in small
quantities and dentist's office
most commonly hospitals but 10,000
pounds of nitrous oxide being moved into
this tank if anyone can find the answers
it's these guys puts a lot of pressure
on this one company if they can pull
this off a lot of other companies are
gonna follow them if they can't if this
crucial problem isn't solved it might be
a long time before you and I get our
spaceflights